M it's
God it's
God yeah you truly believe is everybody
here Muslim who you're Christian God
bless you guys God bless you who else is
Muslim Muslim I follow Jesus Christ yeah
you said you said you said the Jesus
Christ yeah but but you follow Jesus
Christ you have to follow you have to
follow
B you follow you so you said the the
Trinity was made when on the Roman
Empire ined the Trinity cuz the Trinity
is a pagan belief according to what what
do you mean it's a trinity is a pan
belief okay so like like for example if
I were to say uh the belief in Allah or
the black stone is a pagan belief what
would you say to me but we don't worship
you do you you believe that you believe
that touch We believe We believe the
stone Came From Heaven yeah but
just second okay we'll get there in a
worship God but but but you you touch
the you touch the stone and you kiss the
stone right yes why do you do that why
do you do that came from muham Muhammad
said Muhammad said by touching the
corners of the stone it removes your
sins you don't think that that's
Pagan like how can a stone do that but
then the whole but then you're you're
just saying something back to me the
whole Trinity the this is what I'm
saying so then we're equal right right
so this this is what I'm saying here if
you're if you're you're accusing the
Trinity of a pagan belief and so that's
wrong then you should also leave Islam
if you because you guys you know believe
a stone takes away your sins that's
Pagan look look look look no but it's
still not guaranteed it is that's or
unless Muhammad lied did Muhammad lie
where does where did you get that is
that a Hadith it's ath yeah it's a
Hadith us you guys Quran only us show us
show us isi show us wait more Quran or
just Quran Only We believe the Quran is
the word of God while Hadith they're the
I'm pretty sure was the comp right
they're the ones that said the okay
again let so yeah just wait hold on just
to be clear so so are you going are you
explain touching the stone theith some
of it is is listen listen watch
thisth some of it is authentic and some
of is weak okay so is this a weak ADI
that I'm quoting it's it's great all I'm
saying is the same way you want us to
look into the Quran and question it I'm
going to say question the Bible too
because if you look throughout history
if you look throughout history like King
James he got the GRE of Bible and made
his own his own version of the Bible so
that mean not following the Au Bible all
I'm saying is just look at the history
look want me to look into but no so
that's what I'm saying ask you I
appreciate your approach here like what
you're doing right now is challenging
right you're challenging which is good
so but but what I'm saying is is that if
that same energy that you're using to
challenge Christianity you should do the
same thing with Islam okay so if you're
saying that like so when I say you say
that Trin the Trinity is Pagan which I
would love to let's get into it you say
it's Pagan where do you get that from
from Roman Empire I got it from history
wait what what like I need a quote I
need a source what source I'm not I'm
not like you guys are you guys are
trained to do this like I'm sorry but so
then where are you getting this from
because I watched videos on it I looked
into history okay so this is what I'm
saying the Holy Quran say this no no it
doesn't and at the end of day at I'm
sorry but my head hurts cuz I'm sick
right now I'm trying to say the same way
you want us to question the Quan yes I
ask you guys to look into history and
question that's what we
do we could all beong but this is what
I'm saying sister I'm saying that you
haven't done that yet cuz you you you
have a misconception and it's not like
it's not your fault like there's videos
out there there's stuff out there that's
being spread as misinformation but I
don't believe that you yourself looked
into this to see if if the Trinity is
actually a Roman Pagan belief because it
wasn't if you look into it it wasn't
matter of fact it's it's in the
scriptures Jesus taught
this Jesus taught this has nothing to do
with
this so you have yeah exactly so if
we're talking about our
belief our Trinity comes from the Bible
from the Jesus said go out and baptize
in the name singular of the Father Son
and Holy Spirit that's what Jesus said I
truly don't believe that I do believe
there is an authentic Bible but the one
that is here today is not Au why do you
say that okay I got you why do you say
that our history they changed it
according to what here in America when
we had slaves they changed the Bible and
were preaching to the
slaves okay so how do you wait wait how
do you know that that that that was
changed to that that's what I'm saying
if you look that's not giv a source I
know but I'm just saying just look look
into it that's I have that's what I'm
telling you I have and none of that is
true I I have my Bible today that
matches the manuscripts from the uh you
know from 2 Century third Century fourth
Century I that matches exactly what I
have today none of that has anything to
do with black slaves uh Constantine all
is that I don't believe the Bible is
authentic history it's been changed okay
so let's let's talk about this you
believe you believe that the Bible's
been Chang I you don't believe the Quran
is God that's fine but this is the
reason why though but I mean at the end
of the day the Quran says that the Quran
says the Bible can't be
changed but it has so then that means
that Quran is false so you guys should
not be following King James version then
I don't follow King James version I
follow the Bible he follow but I I
follow the Quran the Quran tells me I
should believe in the Bible it did not
say
chap 3:3 of the Quran we have revealed
the Torah and the gospel chapter uh
21:48 we gave Moses the Torah and the
Criterion chapter 5:47 let the people of
the Gospel judge by what Allah has
revealed in it whoever doesn't judge by
the gospel you're a wrongdoer follow the
B the Quran tells me to be a Christian
you need to know what the Bible the
Quran tells me to be a Christian all I'm
saying is that's the reason why I don't
follow the Bible but you don't have a
reason you're just you're just you know
you don't have a reason I am telling you
if you look into history you but where
do you if I say where do you get what
history that's what I'm saying I I I
don't have it on top of my head I'm so
then but you can't so this what I would
say if you if you don't have this what
I'm saying if you don't have the
information ready listen let me say this
let me say this Sor I if you are if
you're saying if you're if you're making
a claim if you're making a claim listen
if you're making a claim about like if
you're making a truth claim this is
false this has paganism this has
contradictions this has been changed but
you don't know where you're getting this
from you don't have a source of where
start saying this from you shouldn't say
that until you have the proof I agree
with that like you have to come prepare
yes come prepare prepared I agree with
that anyways but I'm just saying I'm
just saying my beliefs that's why I
don't follow the the Bible cuz I believe
it's if you believe in the Quran you
should follow the Bible no you should
but that's not the authentic Bible so
then so then Accord believe is the T is
the Torah the word of God I believe
there was an authentic Torah too but y
do you believe that there was an
authentic gospel at one point okay are
those were those the words of God at one
point yes can the words of God be
changed no so then the Torah and the
gospel can't be changed hum are not
perfect I know we're not perfect but God
is right we're some some humans are evil
to preserving uh we can't like it's not
authentic when it com to preserving we
can't preserve human corrupted it and
fil at it but but you just said no one
can change God's words the CH so then
humans can change God's work that's why
as Muslims we believe God that he sent
down the Torah corrupted and then he
sent down the the gospel the Bible it
got corrupted where does the Quran say
that no I'm just telling you this is why
I don't follow those script where does
the Quran say that I'm not I'm not I'm
answering your question so you're
throwing me off going why I don't follow
that I don't follow that because I
believe they've been they've been
corrupted and then so but your Quran
doesn't say that your Quran says no one
can change or corrupt Allah's words if
the Tor listen I'm just telling just
listen just listen for a second look I'm
going with that the Quran is the truth
let's take it that the Quran is the
truth if the Quran is the truth then it
says the Torah was the word of Allah it
says the gospel was the word of Allah
and it also says that the words of Allah
can't be changed so if the Torah was the
word of Allah it couldn't have been
changed if the gospel was the word of
Allah it couldn't be changed so if
you're saying that it was changed that
means that the Quran is false because
Allah's words can be changed and the
Quran lied changed it Inc correct go
ahead cuz you you would agree you would
agree that what what someone can do is
write whatever it is they want down and
say this comes from God this is the word
of God and that's incorrect okay so so
so so men can change God's words then so
the Quran is wrong when it says no one
can change words the change because it
was orally memorized it's an oral
tradition I'm saying when it when the
Quran says to Muhammad it was orally
memorized and it was passed down to
gener orally memorized eventually it was
written okay can man change it that's
why I'm telling you as Muslims that's
why we believe the Quran hasn't changed
because it's orally memorized you get
all the qurans and you burn them we're
going to be fine cuz there's 2 million
Muslims that have it orally we have two
different qurans on us right now one of
do any of you guys read Arabic no he
does you know Arabic
right we can show you we can show you
the different Quran so so so then you're
going against your Quran sorry you're
going against your Quran by not
following the
Bible oh my God D he's freaking that's
what the Quran says you understand
that's what the Quran says
qu the Quran do you understand that the
Quran wait you're pushy I got to meet
your energy no I'm just telling you I'm
just telling you my beliefs why I don't
follow I know and I'm telling you that
your beliefs don't line up with your
with your book trying to say this last
statement because my head hurts and I'm
trying to go home my husband but that's
what I'm saying are you guys are married
yes okay congratulations thank you well
I'm just telling you why we don't follow
the Bible if you promise you want to
look into the the history then I will
I've already done I would look into it
as well I I would question my faith if
you question yours as well I've already
done that that's why that's why I know
that that that Islam as you promise me
right now I do it I do it look I'm
telling you right now you listening I
can't you listening now cuz I heard you
out yeah I do this every day I study my
religion every day I study Islam every
day this is why I know listen can I
finish thank you this is this is you
just said I can finish okay good sorry
this is this is why I know that what I
have matches are manuscripts from the 2
Century third Century 4th Century fifth
century all the way up to Muhammad this
is why I can quote you verses from your
Quran that tells you that my Bible is
preserved and can't be corrupted this is
why I talk to Muslims every day when
they say the Bible's been changed that
goes against what the Quran says so I'm
showing you what the Quran says but you
reject the Quran I'm not rejecting the
Quran I'm just telling you why I don't
follow the Torah or the Bible so then
tell me say say you know what say I
don't follow the Quran Avery I don't
follow the Quran say that I'm not going
to say that you're you're just trying to
make me say something that I don't I
want you to be honest intellectually I
am being honest I'm telling you I looked
into it so this is my point of view what
have you looked you haven't looked into
you can't give me anything just I'm not
trained like you like I don't go home
and be like oh my God let me down so but
it's not about it's not about being
trained it's about knowing what you're
talking about it's about knowing what
you're talking about imagine if I said
something to Christians exactly not
every Christian is knowledge you're
right and then but this is what I'm
saying what I would this is my message
to Christians but if you're a Christian
do not go to a Muslim spouting about
Islam things you don't know if you if
you say something be ready to back it up
is that fair to say I'm being consistent
you guys see you guys do the same thing
Muslims talk to Christians that don't
really know anything they're not
knowledgeable now you're doing the same
thing chrisan I I talk to I talk to
people period look if you're bold enough
if you're bold enough to if you're B
yeah yeah yes I do it's all on my
YouTube channel so this is what I'm
saying if you're if you're going to be
bold enough to say the bible let me say
this cuz I heard you if you're going to
be bold enough to say the Bible is this
Christianity is this it teaches this if
you're going to be bold enough then you
are bold enough in opening yourself up
to criticism to challenging so all I'm
doing is challenging you to substantiate
what you say if you can't then don't say
it that's all I'm saying well I just
wanted I just wanted to defend my
beliefs that's it that's why I'm saying
that's why I don't follow scriptures
okay why do you follow Islam you have a
valid point why do I follow Islam I was
an atheist okay
and I don't know if you want me to
explain my whole story well no just what
what's what's what's one reason why you
believe Islam is true that's what I'll
say the main reason well is Faith the
same way that you believe but I have
reason for my faith I I have a substance
for my faith well I believe um the Quran
is the word of God and it hasn't been
changed okay so all right boom so you
believe the Quran is from God and it
hasn't been changed so if the Quran has
been changed then you would believe that
it's not from
God yes if like I would look into
history same way I looked into the Bible
and the Torah and I find out that it's
been changed then yes I agree all right
perfect
Anthony can you can you get the Hops in
the wor Quan
please oh I know I'm sorry but I I I got
to show you this so I'm about to show
you right now that the Quran there's
different qurans it also has to do with
faith but you're putting faith in
something that has no substance you got
to have substance in what you're
believing in but I believe it's it's
orally passed down okay so then if it's
orally passed down there shouldn't be
differences among the books right I
don't know why you have two books
there's only one there's two that's
that's the point why do I if there's
only one Quan why am I holding two books
then we're all wrong then because
there's The Gua Bible there's the
ethopian Bible the King James Bible and
then there's 100 translations of the
King James so you we could do the
same can I tell can I tell you why it's
different to convert me no I'm not I'm
just trying to make you think your faith
is so strong my faith is so strong for
God I I believe you I believe that this
is what I'm saying though I'm saying let
me tell you the difference between my
English translations and my belief in
that and then your belief about the
Quran I don't believe listen listen okay
very carefully I'm a Christian we do not
believe right that every English
translation of the Bible has to be word
for word exactly the same or else it's
false you believe that about the Quran
you just told me why you believe the
Quran because you believe it hasn't been
changed so you believe word for word
letter for letter it's the same
everywhere if it's any different then
you would reject it as the word of God
that Quran how do I know you're not like
messing with us and you just have your
own like version of the Quran what do
you mean own version of the Quran I'm
not that
artistic yeah yeah ask him he knows this
we show him all the time these are watch
this what
what I talk to God logic online somebody
thanks you know you guys know Arabic Hey
listen they know Arabic become a Muslim
watch this they knowledge at the
end believe is the TRU no watch this
watch this hey what what what does this
say on the cover what does the cover say
what does the cover
say wait wait listen
listen read that one more
time all right yeah right from now hold
on hold on let him read the cover of
this 2 years talking watch
thisal
years so
look this is this is H this is this is
these are two different Arabic qurans
that are different they're mostly the
same I would I can acknowledge that the
a lot of places it's the same but
there's a lot of places where it's
different and the people where it go the
the blue one that's the one that they
use in Morocco okay they banned the red
one they said we don't want to use the
red one okay they Ed the blue one in
Morocco cuz they understand there's a
difference and they don't want the kids
to grow up in confusion about the Quran
so you there's multiple qurans all over
the place all over the world okay then
we're all okay by that logic like I'm
going to look into that but by that
logic we're all screwed then because
there's so many versions of the Bible
too no so this is my point that's what
I'm saying you truly that's not my belie
you're going to fight no no no listen I
don't believe that different English
translations of my Bible prove that my
Bible's wrong you believe that different
Arabic versions of your Quran prove the
Quran wrong so I'm not it's not my
belief this is your belief so why do you
wait okay explain I'm now curious okay
so this why do you follow uh whatever
version you follow why do you follow
that one okay so I I just whatever
version you pick up it's good enough for
you to for you to read it's good enough
for you to read cuz it it it it takes
from the Hebrew the Greek and the
Aramaic that's what now what you can do
is is you can study cuz not every
English translation is perfect so you
can study the original language to see
you know which one is more accurate and
stuff like that sometimes one
translation might you know might not be
the best in C A Certain verse another
one may be better you know it's do a
study but that doesn't prove the Bible
wrong not in my opinion just like if you
if when I see textual variance in the
Quran I don't believe that that proves
the Quran wrong okay I don't you believe
the Bible's uh been like it has it's
been preserved like it hasn't been
changed yeah let me tell you what I mean
by that okay cuz we have a different
idea of what preservation means so in a
Muslim idea preservation of the Quran
means every single letter every single
word is the same in everywhere you go
all the way back to Muhammad that's your
view of preservation that's not our view
our view of preservation even if a
letter or word is different right um uh
in different manuscripts there's textual
variance that's what it's called that
there's a difference in the text but if
the message and the cont text is the
same if the message and the theology is
unchanged and is consistent then it's
been preserved okay so we believe that
the message and the theology is
preserved not the actual text like you
know stuff disappears stuff gets burned
you know what I'm saying so but but what
we do have this is what we have we have
a lot of manuscripts some manuscripts
survived better than others some are
older some are later right but what we
have we don't lose anything some early
manuscripts might not have what the
later manuscripts have cuz they survived
better right with your beliefs you
believe uh what you're like the
manuscripts that are left that you're
following you're going to be saved right
AB absolutely it's interesting yeah yeah
so like it's understanding the different
views of how we look at like what
preservation means what you know all
that kind of stuff means and then when
we understand that together we know how
to communicate that so this is why I
would like I would be a hypocrite if I
said the Quran Islam is false because
the Quran has textual differences I
would be a hypocrite CU that would prove
my Bible wrong you know um so that's
what I'm saying like as a Muslim you
shouldn't say oh there's different
versions of the Bible Therefore your
religion's false cuz there's different
versions of the Quran no what I was
saying is that it's been changed but
like you said I shouldn't say that
because I don't remember the stuff that
I read or viewed but that's that that's
why I'm just telling you why I don't
follow the scripture why I don't follow
the Bible yeah same way I hope you
understand why we follow Islam maybe
like same way it doesn't make sense to
me why you follow the Trinity that's the
same way you look at me you're like that
doesn't make sense why they follow God
or why they follow Allah cuz that's what
we call god well so like that's all I'm
trying to say is that and it's like how
my mom says at the end of the day people
follow what they believe is the truth I
used to be an atheist I 100% believe
that religion was BS and that there was
no God and the humans made it but now
look now I Chang now I believe there's
an a higher power so at the end of the
day like I think these conversations are
good cuz you just taught me something
cuz I like we have Christian friends and
they don't believe the same thing as you
but I'm going to tell them that they
need to believe that cuz if they want to
they believe their Bible is you know the
truth and they need to follow it I'm
going to tell them that but that's all
I'm going to say thank you cuz you
taught me something and I hope we taught
you something and that's it okay yeah we
we good it there it was a good
conversation I know I probably can't
shake your hand but can I shake your
hand yeah but you know air hug you
know but yeah than thanks for this guys
yall take care all right guys that was a
spirit spirited conversation um you know
a lot of times there's a lot of Mis
information spread out there a lot of
false videos spreading lies and
falsehood which as you guys see um can
lead people into just spouting or
repeating things that they've heard on
Tik Tok or a YouTube video and then come
and they're not they can't have anything
to present because it's false you know
and so that gets some people in trouble
I would encourage my Muslim friends be
educated like back you know study what
you're hearing look into the things that
you're hearing because then when you do
you'll see that this stuff is false you
know uh and then you can have a more
honest conversation there's only one way
to God as through Jesus Christ he died
for our sins and he rose on the third
day Muhammad can't do it for you Allah
can't do it for you the Quran can't do
it for you all right that's the message
today I hope you guys learned something
oh my God
a
[Music]